Usa el método de sustitución para resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones y encontrar "x" y "y".
"2y" igual a "x" más 7,
"x" igual a "y" menos 4
Y bueno, el método de sustitución
esencialmente lo que dice
es que tenemos que encontrar a una
de estas dos variables como función de la otra,
para sustituirla en la otra ecuación y así obtengamos una ecuación con solamente una incógnita,
pero déjame mejor aquí escribir las ecuaciones
para que entiendas mejor a qué me refiero.
"2y" es igual a "x" más 7 y por otra parte
tengo que "x" es igual a "y" menos 4
y bueno, como lo que estoy buscando es una "x"
y una "y" que cumpla ambas ecuaciones,
ambas construcciones,
estas dos las tiene que cumplir
esta solución que estoy buscando
y por lo tanto tiene que cumplir la ecuación de abajo
que dice que "x" es igual a "y" menos 4,
de la construcción de abajo tengo que la "x"
tiene que ser igual a "y" menos 4, por lo tanto,
qué te parece si sustituimos lo que tiene que valer "x" según la segunda ecuación en la primera ecuación
para así obtener una ecuación
que solamente dependa de "y".
Es decir, en lugar de poner a "x" en la primera ecuación, la voy a sustituir por el valor de "y" menos 4,
porque yo sé que se tiene que cumplir
que "x" sea igual a "y" menos 4,
justo esta es la información que me está
diciendo mi segunda ecuación
y por lo tanto vamos a enchufar a esta "x" aquí adentro,
entonces me quedaría que "2y" es igual a "x"
pero "x" es igual a "y" menos 4, por lo tanto,
en lugar de "x" voy a escribir "y" menos 4.
"2y" es igual a "y" menos 4 más 7
y este "y" menos 4 no te pierdas, salió de "x",
lo único que hice fue sustituir el valor de "x"
de la información que me da
la segunda ecuación.
Y ahora si, tengo que "2y" es igual a "y"
menos 4 más 7, esto está mucho más fácil
de resolver porque es una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita, vamos a resolverla.
Me queda que "2y" es igual a "y" menos 4 más 7,
esto es lo mismo que "y" más 3,
si ahora resto "y" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
me va a quedar que "2y" menos "y",
esto es lo mismo que "y" y por otra parte,
del lado derecho, obtengo que "y" menos "y" se van
y me queda solamente el 3,
por lo tanto
ya sé que el valor de "y" que cumple este
sistema de ecuaciones es "y" igual a 3.
Ahora lo que voy a hacer es utilizar la segunda
ecuación para encontrar el valor de "x".
Y para encontrar el valor de "x" lo que voy
a hacer es sustituir el valor de "y"
en esta ecuación de morado que tengo aquí.
"x" es igual a "y",
pero "y" vale 3,
a 3 menos 4 y bueno 3 menos 4 es lo mismo que -1
y ya también tengo el valor para "x",
es decir, que el valor de "x" igual a -1 y de "y" igual
a 3 es la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
e inclusive lo podríamos verificar en esta
ecuación de aquí arriba, 2 por 3 es 6,
es exactamente lo mismo que -1 más 7...
¡Muy bien!
si checa.
Ahora, lo que quiero hacer a continuación
hasta que acabe el video es hacer el mismo
método de sustitución, pero en lugar de
sustituir a "x" en mi segunda ecuación,
yo lo que quiero encontrar es una expresión equivalente para "y" para sustituirla en mi primera ecuación.
Es decir, aplicar este mismo método de sustitución
pero en lugar de sustituir a "x", sustituir a "y".
Ahora, date cuenta que esta ecuación de abajo,
si yo sumo 4 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
voy a obtener que "x" más 4 es igual a "y",
"x" más 4 es igual a "y" y esto sale de la
segunda ecuación, estas dos expresiones son
exactamente lo mismo
si yo sumo 4
de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y bueno, entonces ya tengo que "x" más 4
es igual a "y" o dicho de otra manera,
"y" es igual a "x" más 4, ahora qué te parece
si sustituyo el valor de "y" en la primera ecuación,
es decir, en lugar de poner "y"
voy a poner "x" más 4,
cada vez que yo vea
una "y" en la primera ecuación.
Y me queda, 2 por "y", es decir, 2 por "x"
más 4 esto tiene que ser igual a "x" más 7.
Y yo lo que quiero ver es si llegamos a la
misma respuesta.
Y bueno,
¿qué me queda de aquí?
2 por "x" = "2x", 2 por 4 = 8,
esto es igual a "x" más 7,
"2x" más 8 es igual a "x" más 7 y si yo quito
"x" de ambos lados de la ecuación, voy a obtener...
es más, voy a quitar "x" y también voy a
quitar 8 de una vez...
voy a quitar "x" y 8 de ambos lados de la
ecuación, estos dos se cancelan y de este
lado solamente me queda "x", "2x" menos "x"
es lo mismo que "x"
y de este lado estos dos se cancelan
y me queda más 7 menos 8 lo cual es -1.
"x" igual a -1 y ahora utilizando
esta ecuación que tengo de morado,
voy a encontrar el valor de "y",
"y" es igual a -1 más 4, lo cual es 3.
¡Perfecto!
llegué a la misma solución, es decir que
si yo sustituyo el valor de "x" o sustituyo
el valor de "y" llego a la misma respuesta.
Son dos formas distintas
de aplicar el mismo método.